نانسي فيلوسي او المراه الحديديه كما توصف
هي وجه الديمقراطيين اللامع لعقدين من
الزمن
فلوسي تفكر باسدال الستار على مهمتها في
الخدمه العامه فمع مستقبل سياسي غير واضح
وانتخابات تهدد اغلبيه الديمقراطيين في
مجلس النواب والاعتداء على زوجها كل ذلك
اثقل كاهل اول امراه تتبوا هذا المنصب
الرفيع اعتبرها العديد من الخبراء اقوى
رؤساء مجلس النواب منذ اكثر من 100 عام
حيث تراست الديمقراطيين الذين خسروا
الاغلبيه في عام 2010 ثم بقيت على راس
المؤتمر الحزبي وقدتهم الى السلطه مجددا
في العام 2018
وعندما استعاده القياده جاءت باعلان غامض
عن التنحي نهايه هذا العام ليتهافت
الطامحون على خلافتها للحصول على دعمها
قبل حتى ان تقرر وقد راى متابعون ان
بيلوسي ربما اتخذت قرارها منذ اشهر
وبالتحديد منذ زيارتها الى تايوان التي
صاحبتها انتقادات حاده من بكين بل ومن
وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه نفسها
وسواء كانت النتيجه فوزه او خساره
الاغلبيه لا شك ان بيلوسي تركت بالفعل
بصمه تاريخيه على مجلس النواب والكونجرس
والامه الامريكيه بحسب ما تقول واشنطن